[Music]  yeah what's up I love you that's the  first time you've ever told me that who  did I ever tell you how much I love you  [Music]  don't take it personally but if you have  forgotten  I will no good anymore ain't looking for  someone great we will see this  his crown have you seen mom's mom's not  here  don't you remember anything I know you  don't want to hear this thing is moving  out with him yeah I spoke to a doctor  thought it might be a good idea if he  came in to see him why well because I  can't remember I don't remember what can  I do we keep it step inside his world so  he feels needed tell me again how you  met grandma you met in Venice right how  could I forget what if we went back  together  who gave me more hair what you are doing  for your grandfather is extraordinary  if your ability  everyone is dead time  when my day comes remember  [Music]